[Music]
I'm having such a good time and I'm not
knowing I'm [ __ ] up I mean I'm
drinking again I'm doing every [ __ ]
thing you could possibly imagine or not
and then I get a call and on the other
end of the phone says heart Jamie Foxx
loses this is Oprah uh-oh you're blowing
the Jamie Foxx oh really what a nice
thing for her to do it blowing it I said
well you mean she says all of this
galavant and all this kind of [ __ ]
that's not what you want to do so I want
to take you somewhere
so make you understand the significance
of what you're doing flash forward to
now open when he tells me you're [ __ ]
up we go to Quincy Jones houses hey man
listen man you're drunk good man we just
don't want you to blow it baby so we go
in the house
and there's all these old actors black
actors from the 60s and the 70s who look
like they just they just want to say
good luck they want to say don't don't
blow it
Wow and I was like me they like this
almost like an intervention yeah cuz I'm
listen you know me I was going hard I'm
not playing
and then officers okay you wanna you
wanna meet who you supposed to meet here
I said yeah he's right there and it was
Sidney pointing it I was going to say it
[ __ ] sure they brought out Sydney part
again in a tuxedo Wow a glass this guy
ever yeah he says I said hello mister
play I saw you one time you were at the
party do you remember that Allison yeah
I'm well enough his he says I want to
give you one thing I want to give you
responsibility when I saw your
performance it made me grow two inches I
was like so I break down everybody sits
me down it was actually sitting 48th
birthday
they made me understand the significance
of it like a history but because they
said Sydney did it and it was it was a
it was a Carol because it was Granberry
and was a character that we could all
embrace Ray Charles is also a character
that we can embrace you know sometimes
in Oscars the characters that they award
sometimes a little fracture it's just
bigger than you yeah it's way bigger